today on the matt well show two kids
have been suspended for having toy guns
in their rooms while attending a zoom
class we'll talk about
why this push for online classes
represents a threat to parental rights
and also why online learning for kids is
a terrible idea in general
also five headlines including
kaepernick's return to the nfl virtually
anyway and in our daily cancellation
we'll discuss the academy's
hilarious new diversity standards for
any best picture nominee
i actually like them i think it's a
great idea and i'm excited about it and
i'll explain why even though they are
being cancelled for it before we get to
any of that
the show today is brought to you by ero
um look if you if you need to have uh
well everyone needs to have great wi-fi
everywhere in their home you don't want
to be one of those people
huddled in a certain corner of the room
where you get the best
signal you don't want don't do that to
yourself have some dignity get
euro these days your house isn't just
your home it's an office it's a school
as we'll discuss in a moment
it's a movie theater it's a restaurant
all these activities are more
put a strain on your wi-fi it's not good
it's not good enough to only have you
know
one room or two in the house where you
get wi-fi you need solid wi-fi
in your whole house so everyone isn't
working right on top of each other
that's why you need euro
eero and amazon company covers your
whole home with fast reliable wi-fi
inside and out
uh rooms with with uh with bad to no
wi-fi
if you've got dropouts on your patio
eero makes every square foot
of your house and even outside your
house usable by eliminating poor
coverage and dead spots
you'll have a consistently strong signal
wherever you need it you can be you can
be on a work call the kids can be remote
learning you can have um you know
someone could be streaming videos you'll
be doing all of that
and uh and you'll still have the strong
wi-fi if you have
uh euro you know i can tell i can tell
you especially because for me
where we live a lot of my my neighbors
have trouble getting a good wi-fi signal
but i don't have that problem and i've
told them get euro i scream it at them
i bang on their doors in the middle of
the night and i shout at them you need
eero and at this point they're just
starting to call the cops it's getting a
little
a little weird i guess but that's
because i feel passionate about this
what can i say get euro we're uh you
know we're asking a lot of our wi-fi
ero can help yours do more go to
walsh eero.com codewalls and check out
to get free next day shipping
with your next order that's eero e e r o
dot com slash walsh code wall should
check out to get your euro delivered
with free next day shipping eero.com
walsh codewalsh eero.com
okay well as kids across the country um
are attending online school school
systems are deciding that
this expands their jurisdiction and
authority into the very homes where the
children are sitting
so two recent and egregious examples
both in colorado
in one case a seventh grader at grand
mountain was suspended after his art
teacher saw him during his online art
class
playing with a gun teacher wasn't sure
if the gun was real or not
perhaps it's relevant here to note that
the gun was neon green
with an orange tip and it said zombie
hunter on the side of it who knows maybe
the kid was a real zombie hunter
so the police were called and the police
then showed up to the child's house
and the child was suspended for the
zombie hunter neon green nerf gun
another case for this one let me play a
clip from the local fox 31
news report watch this for 6th grader
maddox blow
target practice is just a regular part
of being an eleven-year-old kid
that's why he says he didn't think
anything of it when he picked up the
airsoft gun in his bedroom
after completing a quiz during a remote
school session
online i was just fiddling with it
because um
like i was bored and so i just fiddled
with the
nearest object at hand maddox said he
didn't even realize he was on camera
but hours later a teacher noticed the
airsoft gun while reviewing the recorded
session according to maddox's dad the
fox 31 problem solvers learned a
resource officer then called the wheat
ridge police
to ask for a welfare check and report
that maddox had a toy gun
and now maddox is suspended from school
for four days this was a blatant
overreaction on everyone's part
maddox's own apology the jeffco public
schools wouldn't go on camera but in an
email confirmed the incident
and said the student was disciplined
according to their district code of
conduct
yeah you know we're going to leave
entirely to the side the fact that
suspensions in general are a supremely
stupid form of punishment
the only kids who care about getting
suspended are the kids who
don't deserve to be like the two
students in these stories
in other words only good students
consider it a punishment
to not be allowed to go to school but
good students don't get suspended or if
they do they probably don't deserve it
so
the bad students deserve the punishment
but they're the ones who don't consider
it a punishment
you're bad in school and you act like
you don't want to be here your
punishment is a one-week vacation mister
that'll teach you not very effective but
more to the point
there are all kinds of horrifying
implications to public schools
now punishing students and getting law
enforcement involved
for things they're doing inside their
own homes
yes bringing a fake gun to school will
get you in trouble but
now you aren't allowed to have one in
your home and all because the teacher
can see
inside your home so a teacher can punish
a child
for anything the teacher sees the child
do
no matter where he is when he's doing it
a teacher has
authority over the actions of a child
inside his home
and all because zoom grants the teacher
a view of inside the home
what this coveted panic-inspired rush
towards online learning or distance
learning as they call it now
represents uh what it represents is
among other things a massive
power grab by the state government
schools had already over the course of
the past several decades
been intruding more and more into home
life taking more and more power away
from the parents
as the school itself increasingly
assumes the position
as surrogate parent but now with this
online learning stuff
with households apparently required to
function as the school and obey
its rules what should be a reclaiming
of power by the parents has worked
exactly the other way around
the schools have just extended their
reach
slithering their tentacles into the home
and claiming it
as their domain now and all of that
is also almost beside the point when it
comes to online classes
the most important point of all is
simply that online learning for kids in
grade school
doesn't work in fact it's debatable
whether it
works at all at any age even at the even
at the older ages
a report published by inside higher ed
in january of last year
so way before the covid panics and
everyone running into their homes for
months on end
found that students who are fully online
taking all of their called
college classes on the internet
underperform and experience poor
outcomes
now i ask you is there any reason to
think it'll be better for 10 year olds
there are i'm sure some adults who can
be successful with online classes there
might be some kids too but that
percentage is going to be much smaller
and that's why the reviews after the
last you know
the last three months of the past school
year spent learning online the reviews
for that were generally poor
it was an article in the wall street
journal in june headline the results are
in for remote learning it didn't work
of course it didn't you can't plunk a
child in front of a computer for hours a
day
and expect him to absorb even a fraction
of the information that's thrown at him
children need an education that is
hands-on immersive
personalized in fact the whole problem
with the public school system where 30
kids are plunked into a classroom and
information is spewed at them
which they're expected to memorize and
regurgitate the whole problem
is that it's not nearly personalized
enough
now take that same approach except have
the kids sitting and staring into a
screen
and all of bad things about public
school education at least all the bad
things about the education itself
if not the environment are amplified
you simply can't expect kids to learn
this way there's a reason why
for years the complaint has been that
kids spend way too much time
sitting around and staring into screens
suddenly
because people are scared of a virus
that rarely affects kids at all
many kids are required to do the thing
we've all said they do too much of
already
so we go from you look at screens too
much to
sit here for six hours today and look at
screens one thing we can certainly
expect
there is going to be a huge and i'm sure
we will be told mysterious
rise in adhd diagnosis this year um
kids who have trouble engaging and
staying invested and interested and
focused in a crowded classroom
while teacher reads information off of a
worksheet are already diagnosed as
somehow disordered
when their only real disorder is that
they're disengaged and bored
by stuff that's disengaging and boring
so expect a similar approach to kids who
have trouble sitting still and staring
at a screen for hours each day
well you know this this eight-year-old
boy isn't learning much from five hours
of zoom meetings each day
he must be diseased let's shove some
pills in his mouth
that's what's coming i guarantee you for
a long time
the approach to education has been to do
it
in a way that is most convenient for all
of the adults involved
and if the kids struggle to learn that
way well then drug them until they get
with the program
so a parent says i need to be able to
ship my kid off to a government building
for eight hours a day
because that's easiest for the lifestyle
that i want to have
if my kid doesn't thrive in that
environment well there must be something
wrong with him
put him on drugs no there's nothing
wrong with your kid
there's something wrong with your
approach to parenting
and now zoom classes and online learning
for elementary schoolers is just the
latest example
of educating kids in a way that makes us
feel most comfortable as adults
and is most convenient for us and what
we want to do
but is not good for the kids and so what
do we say
if it doesn't work for the kids then yet
again there's something wrong with them
that's what's coming down the pike i
guarantee it let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
well i want to tell you about omaha
steaks i was really excited the over the
weekend our shipment our latest shipment
from omaha steaks came in
and uh it's just a big box of meat and i
was looking through the meat
and i was very excited about it my wife
was calling from the other room
asking me to help with the bait she want
me to get a bottle for the baby and i
said i'm i
you know we just got a [ __ ] bit of meat
i'll i'll get to that in a second but
let's have some priorities here
um and then we had uh we got hot dogs
and
kielbasa we got hamburgers we did a
whole big cookout
it was absolutely delicious and so i
can't recommend omaha steaks enough
the last thing we all want to do right
now is go to a grocery store it's
crowded you have to wear masks in a lot
of places in the country
um the selection isn't always great you
can't find what you're looking for
instead stay at home and let omaha
steaks ship your food directly to your
door
and it gives you something to look
forward to also you know rather than
just getting bills in the mail you're
going to get a big
hunk of meat in the mail multiple hunks
of meat right now you can get a gourmet
grill out package with an exclusive
offer just for my listeners go to
omahasteaks.com enter code walsh
into the search bar and for this week
omaha steaks will add
four burgers four gourmet jumbo franks
free with your order
this is the grill that's what i had the
grill up package it was great it's
called the grill out
favorites package and it lets you stay
home and eat like you're at the best
steak house in town
we're talking a variety of gourmet
grillables like the omaha steaks
bacon-wrapped filet mignon
visit omahasteaks.com and type walsh
into the search bar in order today
omaha steaks isn't just steak it's the
best steak of your life
guaranteed and not just steaks it's all
all different kinds of cuts of meat
and don't forget when you order the
grill out favorites package you also get
four gourmet jumbo franks four omaha
steaks
burgers free to complete your steakhouse
experience stay home stay safe and eat
great go to omahasteaks.com use keyword
walsh
and order today all right number one
colin kaepernick is returning to the nfl
virtually anyway ea sports announced
that kaepernick
will be in the new madden game um you
can choose
him to quarterback any team you want
apparently his
his avatar uh his his character in a
game will have an 81 rating
which the kids tell me is good so that
places him like among the elite
quarterbacks in the game
which is obviously absurd he wasn't an
elite quarterback when he played five
years ago
here's the statement from ea sports that
says colin kaepernick is one of the top
free agents in football and a starting
caliber quarterback
the team at ea sports along with
millions of madden nfl fans want to see
him back in our game
knowing that our ea sports experiences
are platforms for players to create
we want to make madden nfl a place that
reflects colin's position and talent
rates him as a starting quarterback and
empowers our fans to express their hope
for the future of football
we've worked with colin to make this
possible and we're excited to bring it
all
to you today um yeah i'm sure you did
work with colin kaepernick for that i'm
sure he was he was fully on board
all in the name of social social justice
this is this is all about social justice
racial justice
um but getting colin kaepernick in the
game you know it's all
it's all in the uh when when he was
working with madden
what making however much money he was
making from them to get himself in a
video game
it is all for racial and social
justice okay and money but
mainly for racial and social justice um
now of course the claim as i said the
claim to him being a starting caliber
player at the age of 32
five years removed from the game is
ludicrous
just to give you an idea kaepernick lost
his starting job
to blame gabert while he was still
playing okay
and if you aren't familiar with pro
football
suffice it to say that losing your
starting job to blaine gabbert
is one of the great humiliations that
you can possibly suffer
in an athletic context it's like it's
maybe a notch
below losing an arm wrestling
competition against your wife
okay it's it's only slightly less
humiliating than that
in his final year in the league in 2016
he went one for ten
uh he went one in ten i should say that
was his that was actually his record
uh as a starting quarterback he won one
game played played 11
through 16 touchdowns in 11 games
so again this was at best i mean
generously this was a
mediocre player when he was in the
league he had one or two good years
uh and then it was sort of a
a rapid descent from there um he's not
going to be any better now that he's
32 and has has been doing nothing but
shooting nike commercials for the last
half a decade but this all again proves
my point
that colin kaepernick is one of the
great
con men in american history and
i really believe that i think he's
almost at the level of maybe the kid
from
that the catch me if you can was based
on he's almost at that level
i mean if you think about it colin
kaepernick realized that he was washing
out as an nfl starter
he faced a career as a journeyman backup
quarterback you know signing
two or three year really one or two year
contracts and different
places around the league you know coming
in for for for training camp and then
and then maybe
signing somewhere else um and he didn't
he didn't want to do that so
it was at that moment that he launched
his fake
social justice crusade fast forward five
years
he's far richer and more famous than he
ever would have been
as a professional bench writer it's it's
a hell of a scam
it really is uh and this is why i've
never been able to
generate the same sort of anger towards
colin kaepernick that other
conservatives have
i guess because i'm a capitalist at
heart and so when i see this guy running
a con like this and raking in millions
because of it um i can't help but have
some level of respect for it yeah he's a
scumbag and he's a liar and a fraud but
at the same time
this was just a massive course change
and he was able to sell himself as some
sort of social justice crusader and make
tens of millions of dollars off of it
now granted he had a lot of help from
the media and everything else so you
could say
it really wasn't that difficult but
still
hell of a con hell of a scam that he's
running number two you may remember
speaking of scams
jessica krug the african studies
professor who was uh
who was white but claimed to be black
for many years
video has surfaced of this person back
in 2019
when she was still pretending to be
black and here she is on a columbia
university panel
seemingly justifying and defending some
gang members who hacked apart a 15 year
old
kid with machetes and she says that it's
a it was a revolutionary political act
and seems to have um a not very
disapproving attitude about it watch
how many people in this room are
familiar with um leandro guzman
feliz it's a 15-year-old boy
who was murdered in the bronx last year
um so if you're in new york you probably
heard a lot about this
um and the narrative around it is that
he was an innocent kid who was mistaken
for a bad kid
right he was the kid who was um hacked
apart with machetes
in front of a bodega in the bronx um and
the idea is that he was mistaken for
someone else
by trinitarios right who are dominican
gang
that comes out of rikers as most of the
radical politics of new york city has
done for many many years
but the part of the story that gets
emphasized in different ways is that he
was an explorer
right which is a program that the nypd
has to bring
youth in to eventually work for them
and so when i think about this politics
of silence that i'm talking about in the
archives right and how silence can be
a really radical presence historically i
think it's a radical presence today
when people talk about snitches get
stitches right or when we think about
a history of anti-apartheid struggle in
south africa and necklacing
right and that kind of violence towards
people who are collaborating or working
against
their communities we have to consider a
radical moment
in 2018 in which people are using
machetes to hack apart a 15 year old boy
who's working with the police now this
is not the point i suppose but my first
question is how the hell did anyone ever
take that woman
for a black person i i she's paler than
me
she sounds like a valley girl uh i mean
how did speaking of scams how did this
go on for years couldn't everyone
tell she wasn't black just by you know
looking at her
did she surround herself with visually
impaired people did she work at a camp
for the blind i i mean i really
it's it's amazing to me that that person
passed herself off as as black all those
years
but really i guess it's not that amazing
the reason she got away with it is that
we live in a country where everyone
feels like they have to take
everyone else's self-identification
seriously no matter how
obviously absurd it is so when she went
around introducing herself as a black
woman
people were afraid to just go uh no
no no you're not uh you're you're not
that by
you're assert i don't know exactly where
you're from or what but no
no to use basic common sense is
considered an act of violence now and so
people are afraid to do that
and everybody forfeits their common
sense willingly um
you know uh choosing wokeness over over
common sense
we're at the point now where i could
walk into a room
and say but howdy folks great to meet
you i'm a i'm a
i'm a jamaican woman and uh also i'm 72
and pregnant and i can fly
and everyone would feel obligated to say
okay great nice to meet you how's
vietnam these days
that's where we are um and that's that's
that's how she
got away with it that's i guess it's a
similar thing to colin kaepernick i want
i want to
the positive side of me wants to laud
them for being great scam artists but
then i realize
the culture and the environment has made
it so incredibly easy
to run these kinds of scams number three
michelle obama is offering some marriage
advice in a recent podcast she said
quote
um there were times that i wanted to
push barack out of a window
and i say that because it's like you've
got to know the feelings will be intense
but that doesn't mean you quit and these
periods can last a long time
they can last years
periods of wanting to murder your spouse
can last
years you know having murderous rage
towards your spouse
for any amount of time let alone years
i i i'm not sure that that's actually
good or healthy or normal
um i haven't been married for as long as
as the obamas have been married but you
know we've we've got nine years under
our belt
you know we have four kids and so we've
been around the block a few times and i
can say that i've i've never wanted to
push my wife out of a window
i can say that which actually would make
for a very romantic
valentine's card honey i swear i will
never chuck you out a window
a little too sentimental i don't know
but i just you know i'm a romantic at
heart
number four finally tedx london has oh
no not not finally this is number four
we've got one after this tedx london has
announced that it will no longer use the
word women
and instead we'll use women with an x
instead of an e so uh whimxen
wimixon they explain their decision here
they say
why we're using whimxen no that's not a
typo wimxin
is a spelling of women that is more
inclusive and progressive
the term sheds light on the prejudice
discrimination and institutional
barriers
we mix in have faced and explicitly
includes non-cisgender women
actually okay there's a there's a lot to
unpack here um
or maybe there's nothing to unpack this
is just a load of nothingness
this is utterly vapid meaningless
women with an x is more inclusive how
how exactly it sheds light on prejudice
how what why
when where so many questions um
though i do appreciate this new leftist
trend
i guess of injecting the letter x into
words randomly
because it demonstrates that
progressivism has no ideas of its own
no real vision no plan no goal no
coherent
thought of any kind to offer it's really
reactionary in the most literal sense of
the word
because it simply reacts to what already
exists
its whole thing is just to arbitrarily
tear down and get rid of
what already exists for no reason other
than just to do it
um that's the only discernible or
vaguely discernible reason to replace
women with whimxion
it achieves nothing other than to get
rid of the word women and the only
problem with the word
women is that it's a word people have
used for a long time
and so we're going to get rid of it for
that reason it's the same thing with la
tinx and
and all of these or latin x i'm still
not clear on how to pronounce any of
these words
um or maybe you're not supposed to
pronounce them i don't know it's like
uh you know prince replacing his name
with a symbol is it that kind of thing
i'm not sure
number five finally for our most
important story of the day huge
controversy ignited yesterday when
kim klachek a congressional candidate
from baltimore she's the woman who made
that viral
ad about baltimore uh where she
announced her campaign she posed
uh for a picture at jimmy's seafood
which is a maryland institution best
crab cakes
in the country in the world on the
planet without question
but the picture sparked debate because
as you could see she's eating sushi with
a fork
uh and the comments about this have been
vicious
all focused on the fork because people
say
you're supposed to use chopsticks when
eating sushi
but let me just say right now and and i
will say this publicly and i really did
appreciate this this picture from from
kim um
i am also a forker as we call ourselves
maybe we should think of a different
label than that
uh i eat sushi with a fork i've been
doing it for years
i also have endured the scorn and
disdain for my fellow man because of it
but it is time that we forkers come out
of the shadows and speak our truth
there's nothing wrong with i use a fork
for sushi yes i do sometimes use a fork
for
pizza for hamburgers i use a fork for
anything
it is uh it is a it is a one of the
great
inventions in the history of of of
mankind and there's absolutely nothing
wrong with it so
i appreciated that from kim klaichik
okay let's get to our daily
cancellation today for our daily
cancellation we're gonna be canceling
the oscars
the oscars have been canceled for me on
a personal level since
well forever i don't think i've ever
watched more than five minutes of an
oscar's telecast that's because i'm not
a masochist but
today we're going to be canceling the
oscars for everybody else too you aren't
allowed to watch it either now
after this which i think will will be
one rule that you should have
no problem following under my theocratic
uh dictatorship reading from the
hollywood reporter
the headline is film academy sets
inclusion requirements for oscars
which will take effect in 2024 and this
is good as we all know because
history proves that quotas inclusion
stringent pc standards all of that makes
for great art
for example fun bit of trivia here um
the sistine
chapel was painted by a committee of
racially diverse
lgbt activists it's true um that's a lot
of people don't know that
now let's read the article to find out
about these these requirements it says
to encourage
equitable representation on and off
screen in order to
better reflect the diversity of the
moviegoing audience films will have to
meet minimum requirements pertaining to
representation and inclusion to be
eligible for the best picture oscar
beginning with the 96th
96th oscar race uh which will recognize
achievements from 2024 and be held in
2025.
the academy of motion picture arts and
sciences announced on tuesday saying
that
in the meantime an academy inclusion
standards form
will have to be submitted to the academy
for a film to be considered for the 94th
oscars
and 95th oscars although meeting
inclusion thresholds will not yet be a
requirement
and no action will be required for films
wishing to compete for the 93rd oscars
which are to be held on
april 25th okay now there are four
standards by which the films will be
judged
before being admitted into consideration
for a best picture
and they must meet two of the four
standards so here's the first of the
four standards
uh this is standard a it's on-screen
representation
themes and narratives that's the
category this means that at least one of
the lead actors or significant
supporting actors
is from an underrepresented racial or
ethnic group these groups can be
asian hispanic latinx black
slash african-american indigenous native
american
alaska native middle eastern north
african
hawaiian native hawaiian or other
pacific islander or
other underrepresented race or ethnicity
they might also qualify
under standard a if at least 30 of all
actors and secondary and more minor
roles are from at least two of the
following underrepresented groups
women racial or ethnic group
wait women racial or ethnic group lgbtq
plus
people with cognitive or physical
disabilities or who are deaf or hard of
hearing
or then there's a3 which is another way
to qualify is if the main
story lines theme or narrative of the
film is centered on an underrepresented
group
such as women racial or ethnic group
lgbtq plus people with cognitive or
physical disabilities
or who are deaf or hard of hearing then
there are other standards too uh
standards b
through d but frankly i think we all get
the point now
a number of things jump out jump out at
us here first of all
how is racial or ethnic group an
underrepresented group so racial groups
in general are underrepresented in
hollywood how could that be
who are the people who've been starring
in these movies what are they robots
space aliens
they have no race at all that would
explain a lot i guess but
it seems to me that literally every
movie that's ever been made has featured
people of racial and ethnic groups
ah but you know they're they're they're
looking now for
certain racial and ethnic groups and
they want less
of other groups they just don't want to
put it that way because it would sound
racist as hell
which of course it is second
how exactly are women under-represented
in hollywood
i feel like i see women in movies all
the time women are in movies movies are
about
women there doesn't appear to be a
problem here in fact
these days you can't even watch an
action movie without at least one of the
main characters being a 120 pound
supermodel who can somehow beat up 300
pound men
so there are plenty of women in movies
um
and the third point of course is that
this is all completely arbitrary
you know you got 30 percent of the
people in the supporting cast have to
belong to what to two or more of this in
that group
it's it's all entirely arbitrary and the
fourth point is and this is this is the
main thing i think i want us to take
away from this
this is all good this is all very good
we should be happy about this
yes i am i am canceling the oscars
because of it but it's a joyous
cancellation it's uh
there should be confetti raining down
from the ceiling right now this is a
happy i am happy to do it we should be
happy about it
because there there are two consequences
from this both of them very good
one is that and i think this is the less
likely consequence
that movie studios decide that it they
don't care about winning oscars anymore
uh because the oscars are such a joke uh
because it's been turned into
you know like an hr seminar now you have
to have to follow all these different
rules
uh and meet all these quotas and so
maybe movie studios will say
we don't care anymore we're just gonna
make we're gonna make good movies and uh
and
and as long as people watch them then it
doesn't matter to us and if that happens
then the the oscars become entirely
irrelevant
which i would say they already are but
they they are pushed even further
into irrelevance which i would say is a
positive thing
second consequence potentially is that
movie studios decide no they want to win
the oscars
maybe they want to win even more now
because they get woke points for doing
it
uh because then it will show that not
only is it a good movie but it's a
it's a progressive movie and so they'll
win a lot of credit that way
um and so they'll they'll they'll start
making their movies
in accordance with all these ridiculous
rules so that they can win the oscars
and that will just be the end of
hollywood
that will be the end of hollywood
hollywood will officially be getting
out of the business of making art
and uh it will be fully and totally and
nothing but
in the business of progressive politics
i know you could say that that's already
happened and it has
largely but i still think that there are
you know you do find
real art sometimes coming out of
hollywood there are they they do
sometimes produce
a movie a tv show
that seems to have been made because
simply for the quality of it
for for the art itself i think
this could represent the end of that and
now it's just
totally about the progressive politics
and nothing more
and if that happens then it's the end of
hollywood and it leaves
a giant opening a giant gap
for somebody to come in and fill
and make real art um because
they're still going we're we are human
beings
and we still have an appetite for art
that's not going anywhere and if
hollywood's not going to
fulfill that appetite if they're not
going to satiate that human need people
have for art
then then somebody else will will come
in and take hollywood's place and i say
that's good
that's a positive thing so this is all
good we should celebrate this there's
nothing there's no reason to be uh
to be annoyed by it we should laugh and
be and be happy
as hollywood continues to self-destruct
and commit uh collective
you know uh artistic suicide right in
front of our eyes it's all a very good
thing
and though they are canceled again it is
something that we
we do so uh joyfully
not a lot of joyful moments
unfortunately on this show but that's
that's one of them right there that we
can all take
and we'll end it there for today thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clinton